hello and welcome to this video playing
Iron Butterfly so what is the Iron
Butterfly and doing a Sicilian so we got
the Moscow variation yeah this is a very
greedy approach
okay so 93 and yeah so let's see how
he's going to survive this I mean he'd
spent no time I mean no time to get into
this crappy line and should be lost
really this is basically close to lost
this position I think how is he not
losing this now okay Queen to h5 is
something not the only possible thing to
do let's do it
I mean one of the problems and in such a
game can be that you're totally winning
and the opponent and then you get you
try to kill it off and then you lose on
time so I take on f7 what is he doing
Queen ji for what no doesn't work I came
I wanted to give the check and win I
just wonder if I have something better
but it's okay this is a reasonably nice
I guess it's enough like she made him
It's Made next move
yeah I don't get some games you know
he's playing like every move immediately
and it's just lost I mean what do you
think you can just like move the Queen
ten times and be okay yeah it's very
weird I mean this is known for a long
time to be simply bad I mean why it has
such a huge development advantage it's
not a huge surprise that black is
getting getting killed him okay this is
actually not so precise because of
Quincy form the engine points out it's
still a probably very very dangerous but
engine likes Knight takes d4 more okay
you're not surviving this you have
absolutely no development the night D to
be five threatening Knight takes these
six is also very strong but it was so in
he had yet simply in no time no time to
spend now db5 is also winning I mean
this is just a big threat and and this
you're not surviving either yeah this is
also okay Queen age five I thought II
six would be the move that he was trying
I would have taken
Queeny seven engine engine then just bag
I thought I mean I'm not even material
down plus seven okay hey you take
honestly when I played this I didn't see
Knight f6 I was thinking that here I
wanted to just play a slow move and win
yeah like how or take on f8 or something
after this is also should win no but
Knight f6 is of course quite nice it's
even made yeah like this is made nice
okay guys thanks for watching